from The Daily Mail it's the most
rewarding work we've ever done Canadian
Doctor Who's euthanized 400 people
proudly shares how she helped kill man
deemed incapable of choosing assisted
suicide as another physician says she's
helped 300 die did you guys know that uh
euthanasia is now a leading cause of
death in Canada
that's actually legal in Canada legal in
Canada you can go and it's bad I want to
die and then the bag you got it so we
were just talking about health you were
saying Democrats don't want you to be
healthy no no quite the opposite now
this is Canada so I'm not going to say
it's it's one for one Democrats but this
establishment liberal machine side of
things is all about hey man walk into
the suicide Booth we'll line you right
up yeah it's a death it's a death cult
it's literally essentially a death cult
and literally essentially literally yeah
yeah I mean I mean I mean Bill Gates
said that there's too many people in
this world and the Canadian Health Care
system is uh overwhelmed so uh what
better solution by state government than
of course offer people to uh off
themselves there was a woman with a
chronic illness she could not get health
care and Canada because the system is
bunk so they offered killer instead she
does a commercial where she's like at
least I can die with dignity or whatever
and then like a few days later if the
story goes viral because everyone's
freaking out like yo this is nuts right
this old interview gets released where
she's like please I don't want to die
like I need my medical treatment and
it's just like nightmare scenario death
panels like they were talking about 10
years ago wait a minute Canada is
supposed to have the one of the best
Health Care Systems but they got they
got a death care system now and that's
not even a joke yeah they're they're I
mean look at this even crowd told me
some scary stories about that socialized
Healthcare they got apparel it was
pretty bad yeah and you know what I had
my first experience with socialized
Healthcare being a veteran I used to go
to the VA that's my first experience
having socialized medicine that service
I got at the VA was horrible what was it
like I I could not walk I was in so much
my back
um I I had some family come direct me to
the hospital and they was throwing me
all over the place
throw me just like like a wrap you could
move and I was in pain and they had the
ugliest attitude I thought I was gonna
die they were so rude and so
Unapologetic and the way they was
throwing me wet around and I was in so
much pain
that's the last time I ever went to the
VA were you telling them while they were
doing it like hey oh they know exactly
how much pain I couldn't walk I couldn't
even stand so I hadn't walked in like
two days I hurt my back and I had a
sciatic nerve issue or something like
that so and when I was in the hospital
man I was so scared to death I told my
wife don't leave me here don't leave me
here they gave me two shots and I asked
him some medication I got the hell out
of that and I never went back the
government has no incentive to provide a
good product because they have the
Monopoly exactly and and this is why you
know socialized Health Care is leading
to essentially the government saying oh
you can't get a Mobility Scooter why
don't you just kill yourself which is
absolutely happening right now in Canada
which is absolutely because I'm just a
number you're just a number in the
socialization so it says incapable of um
uh wanting to say that they want suicide
what do they mean by incapable but they
can't talk or no he didn't he he did not
have a serious illness or the capacity
to make informed decisions about his own
health so is he unconscious or it's like
someone who's like yeah I got a mental
illness and they're like yeah we're
gonna kill him anyway wow yo that's like
crazy I'm sorry dude I hate to go full
Godwin's law but that's Nazi level stuff
yeah that's enough where they were like
people who are you know invalid they
would say would they would they would
execute euthanize if you if you've got a
death if you got a decision you're gonna
likely they should be there to ease your
pain but if you're not able to ask for
Youth and being euthanized or not it's
just sick man yeah the first comment to
this story is uh that they're giving
Joseph Mengele a run for his money and
uh they're not wrong yeah they're
absolutely not wrong but this is this is
the first layer of it what's what's the
step two what's the step three
um well the Nazis did skip the first
level they just went and executed them
like they weren't asking do you want to
do it them so at least they're down the
train car and then the next thing you
knew you were in a death camp yeah yeah
Dr Kevorkian he was like those were
terminally ill people and they wanted to
die right people who were really old and
they were like I can't do this anymore
every day hurts right he's like I'm
gonna ease your suffering for you you
know I think about that because what do
you do when you see like a deer hit by a
car and his legs are broken yeah well
it's like you know look we're not gonna
leave it here just to wheeze out and
suffer and die you put out of its misery
right it's an animal though not a person
yeah so I think I think I'm not sure if
it was Sheamus we talked about with this
but that's basically what he said like a
human you try to save no matter what
animals we don't you know it's like we
gotta get suffering we'll put it out of
its misery my view is like if you're if
you're past a certain age if you're
terminal if you've got a time limit then
maybe it's okay to say you know we
figure out a way to give you dignity but
the problem with it is the reason why I
ultimately end up leaning away I think
it was Sheamus said this is that you
open the door the next thing you know
they're going to find the justifications
yeah oh this 15 year old kid oh but
doctor said the doctor's gonna come out
and be like I think he's got two months
to live it's kind of like a gun argument
too you ban rifles then they're going to
come for your handguns you can't well
you can't kind of doing it kind of
already like if you own life support and
you unresponsive they want the family
yes if your brain did though yeah yeah
wow but some peoples came back how do we
even know someone's brain does The
Challenge right yeah so it's like the
doctor might what we're really saying is
like do you trust the doctor and so
you're I don't trust any doctor after
this who think about how scary that must
be if you're if you're if you're like
they call it locked in syndrome or
whatever like you move your eyes but you
can't move your body right and the
doctors shine in the light and you're
moving and the doctor goes look up for
yes and you look up and he's like look
down for now and you look down I think
it's a stimuli I I don't think it's
actually in there and you're like
yeah but this has happened and then the
doctor's like I recommend pulling the
plug and and people like you're
screaming in your mind yeah there there
have been many I mean look there's a lot
of people on the planet a lot of people
of course there are stories like this
it's not it's not you know magical that
it happened people who are paralyzed and
doctors think they're not there and then
they come to later like I could hear
everything did you see that story about
the guy in a coma for like 15 years of
his life and they made him watch Barney
every day
I remembered it he was he was conscious
during it but he couldn't tell them
please turn it off
sorry that's horrible but he's he's
doing well now now I hated when I was a
kid
or not I got so I was like what is this
bull crap
15 years of being forced to watch Barney
every single day or waking up during
surgery from anesthesia I wake up from
surgery give me that any day right now
we didn't get knocked back out for 15
years of Barney the dinosaurs he was in
for 12 years this one guy 12 year coma
and they were playing Barney it's like
God reruns at least play reruns of like
the A-Team or something right it's not
like they was trying to kill him
or maybe they're trying to get him to
get up to change the channel yeah it
felt like just leave it on and
eventually he'll yeah you don't have to
wake up from this he's going for the
remote he grabs it yeah his name if
anyone wants to look at him is Martin
Pistorius is his name
Amazing Story oh that's so that's so
brutal I think yeah I think they were
trying to kill him trying to give him a
heart attack yeah yeah just his blood
pressure is they're like they're in the
room and they're taking his vitals
Barney turns on and then they're like
wait something's happening his blood
pressure is rising what are you doing I
don't know I was tapping his hand and it
was like Barney's saying I love you the
guy inside the coma he was smug he was
patronizing he Barney was not a good
person okay he was not a lot of people
have it twisted on him he was defense he
was dinosaur but now imagine you see
they were grooming kids to like
dinosaurs because now if a dinosaur shut
up it's gonna eat somebody and the kid's
not he's being tricked it's like it's
like when the cat gives the rat
toxoplasmosis yeah and the rat doesn't
fear the cat anymore and the cat eats it
yes there you go that's exactly that's
exactly it's some big hippo propaganda
like hippos are the most nasty like
dangerous animals on Earth yeah they are
but I was a Hungry Hungry Hippo was like
the cutest
videos them coming at you like you ever
see those big mouths oh man bro have you
ever seen them fight no you don't want
that smoke Dude tell me right now you
don't want that at all yeah
hippo no you don't even get no I don't
care if it's the pack up they run away
every time I remember Barney man when it
came out it was I was just like getting
out of middle school or high school or
something so I was just like ebbing out
of that kind of show but my younger
brother would watch it and it was like
the weirdest like disgusting saddest
like Make It Stop kind of met my mindset
it was it like brainwashing was that
like they were singing them these weird
Rhymes it was so annoying I just think
it was annoying I I'm not sure there's
anything
hey I don't know man how about this I
remember I was uh I had my little boy
and I was in the living room right and I
heard some I thought it was a gay guy on
TV I said who the hell is gay guy on the
team I can hear him from the living room
I went in on his SpongeBob SquarePants I
was like what the hell is this yeah I
love SpongeBob yeah yeah this movie see
came out loved I was like growing the
door like yeah
but he gives he gives his memes like the
one where SpongeBob and Patrick burn
everything down and then say we saved
the city yeah yeah right right it's like
you slide the Democrat D on it and
you're like there yeah yeah that's what
that's what it is I love that character
in it first movie came out Dennis yeah
oh yeah I love Dennis I love that
SpongeBob movie
and I love it yeah yeah that's good I
mean there used to be some good kids
shows they were always adult jokes in
them that were hidden subtly you know I
love the old Tom and Jerry cartoons yeah
that's funny Yosemite Sam he was an ass
woman you know what's a crazy fact is
that people think Nimrod means idiot but
it was because Bugs Bunny called Elmer
Fudd Nimrod right right sarcastically
referring to him as the great hunter
uh-huh so he was like Hey Nimrod yeah
and then people who didn't know anything
about I thought I'm an idiot or
something exactly because because people
watching Bugs Bunny didn't understand
the joke Nimrod is the great hunter
right Elmer fudd's not oh yeah so we
called him Nimrod and then everyone
assumed he was calling him an idiot
Nim Mirage yeah they canceled all those
cartoons because they said it was
teaching violence to kids no man yeah
and then they started making video games
they call it walking simulators have you
heard about this this has been for a
while now
video games and movies are all violent
right like watch watch any you know I
was watching uh the the trailer the
there's some kind of like live stream
for the new Harry Potter video game and
it's like it's Harry Potter it says
Millennial woke as they come the kids
love this stuff
and then it's like he goes and now for
combat and then it shows some dude like
levitating a guy slicing him up and
slamming him into walls and I was just
like you know this combat's a part of
like how we play games yeah right but a
lot of woke people want to remove that
element and make games about like
holding hands singing like planting
flowers
no hey man look look you know there
there's some there's some games what's
that game that ever plays we knock on
the island you know what I'm talking
about Minecraft no my but Minecraft's
got some violence because you got hidden
cactuses or something yeah those weird
little monsters what's those creepers
trying to ruin your houses no but
there's a game there's a game where
you're on like an island with a bunch of
animal people
you know are people people can tell me
what that game is in the chat you know
what I'm talking about I don't know the
animal people yeah you know what I'm
talking about animal people man and uh
Harvest Moon Harvest Moon is that it
with the animals yeah and like you what
do you do like you plant a garden or
something yeah you just like you like
live a life you mean furries are you
talking about furries I don't know about
that this room with stardew Valley yeah
that's one of the new ones that's the
new Harvest Moon yeah oh I see there you
go that's what I'm saying I was saying
like not every game is violent you know
but they're trying to take violence out
of games and it's like look you play a
game it's fine fine now what they're
doing is they're trying to make Grand
Theft Auto woke by making the main
character a female so it's like so if
you want to bang hookers and shoot
people you can be a woman when you do it
now dude that's wokeness I guess you
know what game is super racist and
violent chess
it's the blacks versus the ones the
whites are the aggressors
and they're all killing each other
it's essentially a good point gotta we
gotta change the color of Chester like
uh uh like blue and light blue damn well
better because it really indicates like
Middle Eastern Conference
you changed it to red to blue and then
it's the Blues versus the Crips no no
you do blue and light blue everybody's
blue but you can tell them apart right
right or you just do numbers like the
ones and the twos no no no one side is
the a side and the side is the one side
that way no one's beneath each other and
no one's a different color you got a
board full of all the same color pieces
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time